19:28 the first winner for outstanding
motion picture was wings in a few
minutes we'll know the 50th the film's
nominated for the Academy Award this
year are Annie Hall Jack Rollins Charles
H Joffe productions Unitas United
Artists Charles eights Jaffe producer
the goodbye girl Ray Stark production
metro-goldwyn-mayer Warner Brothers Ray
Stark producer Julia a 20th Century Fox
production 20th Century Fox Richard Roth
producer Star Wars a 20th Century Fox
production 20th Century Fox Gary Kurtz
producer the turning point Hera
productions 20th Century Fox herbert
ross and Arthur Laurents producers
is Annie Hall Charles age stuff
seven months ago while I suited when I
thought to suggest that I start
preparing for this and this afternoon I
told woody that if it happened I would
try to be a little dignified and he said
I'd probably win in acting or what if I
could do it well the truth is I'm not
very prepared and I don't feel very
dignified but I want to say just a
couple of things about how a film maker
like woody evolves about seven years ago
David picker brought us into United
Artists with the simple words would he
do your thing and through the years we
have gotten nothing but support
encouragement help and love from Eric
Klesko Arthur Krim Gabe Sumner and Danny
risen er they've allowed woody to mature
into a fine filmmaker this is truly an
exciting night for all of us I guess we
all fantasize about something like this
happening and now it's a reality I'm
very pleased and thank you
I understand that Bob Hope had made a
statement earlier today that Woody's
nomination was going to have some
importance in bringing comedy forward in
the Academy Affairs and if his winning
tonight is another step in that
direction I'm delighted I want to thank
the members of the Academy for this
great honor thank you